the studies have shown that playing
games is awesome
and good studies and that and that
you're happy playing the games but the
studies have shown that your
satisfaction with uh playing the games
declines in your mid to late 20s and
then it starts to become less
positive and wholesome and fun and a lot
of people are moving on and by the way
like i've seen this in people i'm close
to um and the main reason for your all
of a sudden clicking in and being like
okay like i'm in the game this happened
to me too like i was gaming gaming and
then eventually i was like oh no and you
know like the single biggest thing for
me was like oh i'm i'm i'm gonna try and
date a woman find a relationship um and
there was an instinctive part of me that
was like i don't know if they're gonna
be into the gaming thing i mean some
women do accommodate it yeah so it drove
me in a particular direction at that
point and so the studies have shown that
this is a very consistent pattern the
social perks and incentives to not be
gaming all the time are pretty high at a
certain age and so that's the threshold
time
where if someone then ventures out into
the real world and let's say they find
something completely unwelcoming and
inhospitable then they'll be like all
right [ __ ] that and then go back to
gaming and then and then the gaming
satisfaction will also decline over time
and then you know like this is not a
great track right um when they go out
into the world and they're like okay hey
what's out here like you know do i have
opportunities relationships progression
and they get that then they're like okay
like i can i can follow this so when
that
boy or man
reaches out and tries to head down that
direction
uh what do they find yes and if they
don't find i mean if they put themselves
out there and they find themselves
rejected or embarrassed or
questioned their masculinity or manhood
whatever it is they fail
then it seems a lot safer to go back to
video games sure
[Music]
[Music]
this week on forward the launch of lobby
three what the heck is that you can find
out also
trucker convoy in canada
video games and boys so much more this
week on forward
[Music]
zack we are back and we are announcing
something big and exciting
the arrival of lobby three we've been on
the grind
we have been yeah you're always kind of
on a grind but i've been we've been
doing some behind the scenes grinding on
this working on and so people who've
worked with me for a while know that
sometimes when i'm doing something i'm
excited i'm just like hey we're doing
this yes
in this case we've been working on it
for
a number of weeks and months and haven't
talked about it openly until now so what
the heck is lobby three
lobby three
is
our effort to help explain web3
technologies and their potential to
combat poverty
to
the folks in dc the regulators the
lawmakers to make sure that they don't
do something
that
stifles this innovation before it can
even really
get going or reach its full potential
super pumped about it and i want to
retrace my steps through
the last number of years we're getting
into crypto
we're entering the metaverse
is anyone surprised
no if the headline is andrew yang gets
into web three
i i've sort of had one foot in one foot
out for a while though as a political
figure i didn't go too far in because
uh you know
it was going to be over the heads of a
lot of voters and like there are a bunch
of other things
but my first major interaction with this
community was speaking at conferences
and events when i was running for
president consensus was one of the first
ones right yes around there there was a
blockchain for good conference i
attended in san francisco
and meeting
these people uh first it was like these
are these are my people it's like my
truth they were your people yeah yeah it
was it was very optimistic
entrepreneurial
like
and nine out of ten of them were for
some version of ubi
yeah as well and i would say the vast
majority were like yang gang or yang
gang and jason although the vast
majority probably didn't vote no offense
we love you
uh
if you had voted we might have been a
different you might be having this
conversation at gracie mansion well
there might not have been that many in
the i'm sure yeah
but so my interactions with the
community were always very energizing
and invigorating it became evident that
if you're trying to combat poverty this
is maybe the single greatest opportunity
that exists today
because you've had hundreds of billions
of dollars worth of value
and thousands and thousands of jobs
generated
over the last number of months really uh
surprising just about anyone uh if you
were to rewind the clock gosh not even
that many years right you know five
years yep i'd say so couple things a lot
of folks
so i found that people either turned on
by crypto or been or have been turned
off right where you're like this is the
greatest thing in the world and they're
down a rabbit hole and they're starting
nft projects and all stuff or
they're like screw this it's a bubble i
don't understand well here's what you
think yeah so a lot of people interact
with it in a very superficial way
the potential of the blockchain has been
clear for a while where imagine
you have
this is a technical term but they talk
about as a distributed ledger um but
let's imagine that you had a slew of
interactions
that no one can affect or alter so that
you can trust everything
and that if anyone does make any kind of
move then it's evident for all to see
correct so if you had that kind of
system you could vote securely you could
have a completely different broadly
accessible financial system
you could have a truly distributed
internet that's not controlled by a few
mega corps you would take out a lot of
middlemen
you could get rid of a lot of accounts
and lawyers
because there are a lot of major
professional services firms that their
uh primary value is papering up a
transaction that if you could document
it on the blockchain then problem solved
i actually remember this
so i was a an unhappy corporate attorney
for five months you were in investment
banking yep so management now i remember
there was a big
acquisition that
uh we were papering up and at the end of
the acquisition
a partner at the law firm had to sign
something saying hey this is
uh this is legally acceptable and that
partner joked with me that that converse
that
signature was worth a million bucks
because really it was this
very high-end law firm putting its name
on the fact that this is kosher this is
legal everything's gonna be fine like
that that firm placing its
brand and reputation behind the legality
of the transaction was what was being
paid for in many ways yes so you end up
not needing any of that because you
could see for yourself that this is
legit yes so when you talk about the
potential of this technology it is vast
and has been for quite some time yes now
in terms of the
applications and implementations to date
have we reached that level no nowhere
near it nowhere near nowhere near it
that's what's exciting and so what
you're seeing now is a bunch of
applications that people can look at and
say um well
you know i'm
unsure whether
this
uh is going to be what's built on this
technology long term
it's like a lot of other new
technologies where they're going to be a
slew of applications and implementations
think even for those who remember this
stuff when the internet first came out
there were like a ton of different
websites
and then when the bubble
popped a lot of those websites went away
but you had some game-changing companies
uh like amazon and paypal and others
that you know stood the test of time
correct um now there's already been a
couple of boom bust cycles um in crypto
but there are going to be some
game-changing companies that come out of
this 100
yes and it will be
this isn't going away that's like that
what i'd say is this is you and i
we were running for president when like
the early adopters were really getting
in right you could still say it's the
early adoption phase a bit but they had
super bowl commercials not that early
anymore um
but when we were running a lot of folks
were getting into this and we're like
this is cool
not sure what it is that sort of thing
and then we've been spending
the last
definitely last four months
like hard like very intently in this
space um intensely in this space but
probably last six to eight months like
really
um exploring it like at least casual and
talking the leaders in it and trying to
figure out okay what are the problems
what are the needs yes and the single
biggest problem that we heard over and
over again was hey we're concerned that
the legislators and regulators don't get
us washington dc is going to mess us up
yeah i mean there was some language in
the infrastructure bill that defined
brokered deal in a way that encompassed
essentially everyone under the sun it
made no sense
and if that were implemented then it
would really
uh
offshore a lot of this industry which is
exactly the opposite of what you want
right
so we heard over and over again
that these stories aren't being told the
use cases aren't being explained
properly uh there's a caricature of both
the people in the industry and what it's
being used for so the caricature is uh
hey this is all being used for illicit
drug deals and human trafficking and the
rich kid that looks like me to sell his
monkey and the people that are using it
are
uh either bad actors or tech bros uh or
um people
who haven't
you know had any needs um meanwhile in
reality when you start interacting with
folks who are part of this community
there are a lot of artists who are being
compensated for their creations in a way
that was completely not possible before
and by the way it has changed our lives
from
you know living hand to mouth or even in
some cases living in their car i mean
you've got extreme cases where people
were yeah homeless to
like either millionaires but you have a
lot of artists they're like i'm able to
fund my lifestyle now yeah um that's
like the more
average case than the extreme ones that
we hear about sometimes yeah and so
there were a number of things that
really were hand in hand with
uh the presidential campaign where one
of the reasons why we were so pro
universal basic income is that it could
give rise to a creative economy and
that's what's happened
uh with web 3 in many cases
we also wanted to find a way to monetize
different types of positive social
actions
because and this is linked even to the
conversation we've been having around
men and boys and jobs and a bunch of
other things where if you had a system
of
tokens and rewards and incentives for me
volunteering in my community helping my
neighbor
grandma taking care of grandma working
out like doing something positive for my
mental health like you know what
whatever it is
then you can create
a new
network and also a set of structures
that help give
people
men in particular
a degree of reinforcement and
purpose and fulfillment and so this is
something that i actually this is funny
on the presidential um so uh it's in my
book and a lot of you read my book the
war on normal people and i called it
digital social credits
um
and by the way zach is laughing because
early in the campaign he was like you're
not allowed to talk about digital social
credits ever again
um because the asian guy talking about
digital social credits just seems like
you know
frankly china social engineering and
like blah blah blah you were also
already far out you know what i'm saying
you're already the free money guy or ubi
you had a bunch of new ideas and then
this one was like so far out and i we
understood why you did it like if you
ever talk to you but it was just another
thing you had to explain yeah so clearly
the idea of digital social credits and
tokens it's already happening yes now
uh in the metaverse with web3 and crypto
so
uh so there were a bunch of things that
were super aligned about the vision and
when the leaders in this community were
to identify a need some of them would
say you know what
andrew you'd actually be really good fit
to help make this case because you were
like a political actor who has
relationships on both sides of the aisle
and a public profile and what many of
them did not know but now they do know
is that uh we had started an advocacy
organization in dc that had been doing
this sort of work around anti-poverty
measures like cash relief and
enhanced child tax credit
and so it really is a perfect fit
because
this can be
the next big step in fighting poverty if
and if we're able to demonstrate what
these technologies can do to enable for
example like a
poor
neighborhood in ohio or washington dc to
get access to financial services in a
way that they couldn't before and by the
way not just to access but i have some
buying power right so we looked at this
space and we're like how can we help
and the first one's like well we could
start a company here and do some cool
stuff and let's i'll be honest like
i think we do have both of us personally
and together like there's some cool
business ideas like the sky's the limit
here new frontier very exciting
but the biggest thing that was missing
was like that's where everybody's going
that let's call it human greed or
interest there and what's missing is
this whoa i mean you're talking about i
mean you could bank the world on
blockchain
in a way we've never been able to do
before you can create value out of
almost nothing the right way and
incentivize certain behaviors and create
communities you're talking about i mean
you're talking about tech that
eliminates poverty
this is it right this is the closest
we're going to get probably in our
lifetime who knows right it can
eliminate bureaucracy too and we all
know how much i
dislike bureaucracy yeah so uh so that's
where we went yeah yeah so
there's a
need and opportunity and we are filling
it with lobby three so if you are
in the
web3 community please do check out lobby
three join the dow
join our discord and uh let's make the
case together if everything i just said
is greek to you do not worry about it
don't
just know that we are trying to make it
so that some of these technologies end
up improving people's lives in the real
world as quickly as possible so we are
going to
andrew is going to do i'll help if i can
but andrew's going to do
a probably a big circuit around like
getting this to we're going to go to the
crypto community right we're going to
denver this week to the eth conference
we're going to go uh
on a number of shows and podcasts and
twitter spaces
we believe in meeting people where they
are right um
but generally speaking i want to make
sure i summarize this so before we move
is that we're going to
make sure
web3
is reflective of the community voices
and the people's voices from an
anti-poverty eradicate poverty lens and
perspective and so it's lobby3.io you
can check it all out it's going to be
fantastic it launched today super
exciting
and
we could do a whole episode on it we
probably will get carly on to do some
dive ins but um we're not going to bore
you with everything because if you hate
crypto we don't want you to or you know
it's just not part of your life no
worries or if you hate lobbying i don't
know
yeah yeah
it's a very wholesome project i'm super
excited about it it has the potential to
change millions of lives the better yeah
and i think you're like the crypto the
web 3 space doesn't have a lot of
politicians like in there
marco rubio came out was like i love
crypto i'll be your crypto guy it just
wouldn't work right i do think you have
a unique role that you can yeah and and
part of it too is you want to avoid it
being politicized in a particular way
and in this day and age unfortunately if
like someone comes out for it then
something on this side will be like i
don't like it yeah um so
behind the scenes yeah yeah you'd like
to just try and make the case in a
positive
wholesome way that look this is going to
change people's lives the better it
already is yep so lobby3.io it's going
to be fun check it out join the discord
we'll be in there carly's in there
a bunch of friends are in there andrew
wang is in there a couple
let's call it crypto innovators and web3
innovators it'd be fun it's time to make
the metaverse safe for innovation keep
all of that value generation right here
in the us of a where it belongs
don't offshore it to parts unknown let's
keep it here
you give
this community a voice in capitol hill
the right way and this guy is i mean
objectively this guy's the limit my
opinion well right now this is one of
the biggest risks overhanging the whole
industry it's like you look up and be
like uh what will regulations be we're
well past the point where anyone in my
opinion can expect a lack of regulation
or taxation correct like it's coming so
the question is is it going to come in a
benign transparent
way that balances the concerns that's
thoughtful yeah because you have two two
major things one is
uh is reduce risk and the other is fuel
innovation uh and growth in new
offerings and so if you get that balance
wrong um you can destroy a ton of value
the entire industry does have
uh in my opinion like uh you know like a
discount or risk is associated with it
because people don't know
where the regulatory could drop to zero
at any point regime or it could be you
know very very extreme where the
government's like hey this stuff's
illegal um so
there's so much opportunity to be had
with this technology uh it's super
exciting can't wait to help it reach its
potential if we can
but the single biggest thing we can do
is just
convey a broader more realistic sense of
both technology and the community to
people in dc we're going to dive in and
like i think we'll be able to educate
some of this community about how
lobbying works and from our experiences
and and experiences of the organizations
we work with but also we'll learn from
them realistically too um but if you're
wondering
is this worth it i think the question to
ask yourself is
did washington dc get web 2 right
absolutely not like we're still reaping
the or paying the price for
either ineffective or bad regulation
uh
from the let's call it the facebooks in
googles and data sharing and things like
our lack of
data privacy and things like that so
um
if web3 is that much more innovative and
scalable then the consequences will be
that much more
worse and more ineffective um more
painful so that's like where my head's
at it's like if they screwed it up last
time we needed we need to at least try
to prevent them from doing that well the
glory of web 3 is that it naturally
enables decentralization yeah and and
it's one reason why the government
generally has this reflexive
um overreaction towards it
um and so you know again you just want
to balance things like are there risks
associated with it yes should there be
taxation yes
but do you also want to make sure that
builders can build and innovators can
innovate and the jobs stay here if you
look at the risk reward it's like the
reward is enormous
and so you just have to try and have uh
an intelligent
way of both uh
measuring and managing the risks as
quickly as you can the reward changes
everything that's what this will the
rewards like you know it's infinite
since yeah it could easily be trillions
of dollars
millions of jobs
millions of lives improved yes
um
doing things without having to wait for
the government to do them like that's um
you know and and that's where the
government
participation is is key it's like
they're like if they're not involved but
they say if you're not at the table
you're on the menu
i've been an entrepreneur for a long
time and you know the worst feeling in
the world
waiting in line at the post office time
is money and you cannot waste your time
doing something that you can do from the
comfort of your own home with stamps.com
you can print official postage right
from your computer save time money give
you better records and make your
customers happy for more than 20 years
stamps.com has been enabling small
businesses and individual consumers like
you
to power the post office right at home
stop overpaying for shipping get things
done better faster cheaper at stamps.com
sign up with promo code yang for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial free postage and a digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
necessary just go to stamps.com click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code yang you'll be glad you
did
[Music]
you know what you're talking about
the trucker convoy in canada yes because
there's too much going on
in the news on this i don't know what
the hell is going on who would have
thought that canada
would beat the united states to a
trucker the great trucker riots that you
predicted
happened 2017 2018
are happening in canada not for the same
reason never would have guessed it
though it does turn out that a
significant
percentage of the resources have come
from the us fyi yeah
the donations yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
there's some solidarity happening so the
canadian government changed their rules
around uh vaccination saying hey if
you're a trucker and you're crossing
back into canada you need to be
vaccinated right you can't come back you
can't clear you're not vaccinated right
right
so uh so there are a number of people
that
hate this rule um now bear in mind the
vast majority of truckers are vaccinated
correct and we have this rule in the u.s
it's like the rule itself apparently is
not
the root it's the the catalyst but
there's other issues besides this
specific rule uh so a number of truckers
have protested their demands are well
beyond this vaccine mandate though like
it's generally you could consider it
something like of an anti-government
protest and it's like eight to ten
thousand truckers or so at least yeah a
lot of them brought their families
uh so that they're startling up traffic
they are disrupting
international trade routes uh i have
been to the ambassador bridge which is
the bridge between michigan and canada
as the largest single
uh it's like ottawa
their main they're mainly in downtown
ottawa and then they're blocking
basically michigan and or detroit and
ottawa as like
main trade route right yeah my friend
stephen marsh is was put uh reporting
directly from the protesters oh was he
really yeah
he lives in toronto and and there are
good for him uh protesters right there
okay so the protests have been going on
for a while they've been extraordinarily
disruptive uh canada has something of a
different interaction than we do where
virtually no
mainstream canadian politician is for
this none none
it's it's not like you can imagine it
here in the us where it'd be polarized
and even now i mean a bunch of the
mainstream uh conservative outlets like
fox and and whatnot are essentially pro
truckers yep um
but that there's not an equivalent up in
canada
uh i think the disapproval rating of
these
protests in like the 70 to 75 percent
range like most canadians are like what
are you doing it's a more liberal
country right general like compared to
the united states so yeah it's got a
different set of relationships where the
state has a bigger role in your life
yes um so i'll give you an example
when covet hit the canadian government
was like hey let's give people some
money
um but it wasn't the way that we did it
where they pumped it out through the irs
they like set up a website and was like
want some money like take it yeah you
know like they they have that kind of
relationship with their people where if
you were in need you could go and get it
and they just issued money hand over
fist
uh the health care provided by the
government
um education free through college you
know if you go to these universities so
it's a much bigger part of your life as
a result
um i think that the
general sentiment against
these protests is
much higher than maybe would be here in
the u.s even uh you know i'm gonna
suggest 70 to 75
uh disapproval of the these protests is
pretty high do we have anything in this
country like that you could get
percent on yeah it's like it'd be tough
um
so
what does it all mean
um the first thing is the direct impact
of these protests themselves which by
the way uh are significant enough where
they're screwing up the supply chain for
a whole number of things um it's not
great i i had a friend who had his
purchased item which was significant it
was like an automobile or something
already like
delayed as a result of this and and
things like that like that like it's
having
an impact already you've got companies
cutting shifts and stuff too it's not
just people ordering it's folks that
make these products if you can't get
certain parts they don't try and build
it that day and people lose shifts they
lose income yeah
will there be
uh copycat convoys in other parts of the
world completely there already are yeah
they're not major but it's like there's
one in new zealand there's one um i was
reading about i mean they're small and
they're not major yet but yes they will
and they haven't really happened in the
us yet although there's rumblings yes so
so that that's uh another phenomenon
that i think you can foresee like if you
were to say will there be a significant
uh protest uh in america that's led by
truckers in a similar way over the next
you know like
you know number of months you'd have to
say almost certainly yes
canada's response to it um has been
interesting too where they're completely
against uh exceeding to any of the
demands and most people just want them
to break it up um so they're they're
taking some relatively extreme measures
where trudeau is relying upon something
around like a war powers act essentially
yes saying
uh
we're gonna do whatever it takes
including
uh freezing assets uh potential
uh physical removal
uh and the public is behind him yeah
it's they're not [ __ ] around in terms
of their stance against this and i mean
they meaning the canadian government now
do you have a sense of what they're
protesting because it's not
just that mandate for truckers it seems
to be
a little bit bigger but still related to
covid a sense of marginalization among
people who feel like their point of view
is ignored people who are very
passionately
uh against being forced to
vaccinate
you know and so that's the truckers
directly now one of the things that is
happening that is very very upsetting to
me
is that there are some people with very
extreme points of view who are among the
thousands of truckers who are flying
you know hate symbols and the rest so
there was a small group of
swastika-swinging confederate flag
swinging
protesters and then they did i think
they've pulled out about 13
maybe a few more weapons from which is i
mean of 8 000 not a lot but so one of
the things that happens in these
uh episodes
is that you will seize upon
someone among the group and say see
this is a bunch of
hate-filled uh
extremists with weapons and the rest of
it and by and large
according to stephen who's physically
been proximate to these things
they're peaceful
kids are walking by like this is not
like you know
like something where
uh in a way you could try to be like
it's still canadian
let me ask you this quick aside but i
think it's important what's the
difference between what you're talking
about here you've got a group of
truckers and trucker supporters eight to
ten thousand and there's a small subset
that are [ __ ] racist right well one
of the things that happens is anytime
you have a conflict
or
uh demonstration or protester or of some
kind extreme elements will show up oh
they come out of the woodwork like it's
yeah it's like why weird people are out
on halloween too it's like you can get
the opportunity for the crazies to come
out they're going to take it right this
is why you know what's going to happen
in the us in some form because as soon
as someone plants a flag there are some
people be like oh it's go time right so
you have this on and this is called
let's call this is what the right looks
like when they have a protest but but
and this is in many ways the strains you
have to pull apart which is that uh
they're going to be some people with
very very extreme ideologies that are
looking for a fight
um but and so your temptation then is to
validate whatever the genesis is of the
protest
and say well you're all terrible right
um where they can there can be
the seeds of something very reasonable
and even uh sympathetic yes but then it
ends up getting
twisted particularly by news media
accounts now let me ask
is this similar to what we saw with the
george floyd protests and the black
lives matter protest where you had a
large swath of people that were for
like or against police brutality like
this has to stop we need fundamental
change and systematic justice reform in
this country but then you also had
people looting and burning buildings
throughout and the right was saying well
look at these [ __ ] they're lighting
our stores on fire we can't stand for
this um and the left was saying they're
mostly fast majority protests right same
thing like what's the the destruction of
property sounds like a line there like
to me
i like saying things are the same but i
do like having a line you know where a
swastika that's [ __ ] up but you're
always gonna have that [ __ ] up person
are they hurting anyone are they
disrupting like where's that and on the
left
i don't mind crazies being out there per
se but if they're lighting things on
fire and destroying property and
business well that's one of the problems
that if you're ideologically opposed
uh you tend to look at it and then
attribute whatever the heck the yeah
negative is of it yeah um where you know
most of the people who are showing up to
these
protests in canada are apparently again
perfectly peaceful a lot of them have
kids with them themselves
um so
you know that there are
um
i'm sure people that if you met in
person you'd be like oh this person's
like reasonable and
sympathetic yep uh
the same is going to be true here in the
u.s there's going to be some legitimate
gathering and then it's going to become
dark pretty quick to me it's kind of
saying don't throw the baby out with the
bath water like what's the core here
right like what are the majority of
people
upset about and like what's the common
ground am i you know and that's and then
both
both sides right
barry weiss has a sub stack so barry you
were on her pod six months ago or so um
but she did she's one of the best folks
right now i find in doing like objective
journalism in written form and she finds
other journalists that are great too but
she had a sub stack um that we'll we'll
plug here but it's rupa i'm gonna
apologies to her for i think it's her
for um messing up the last name but
subraman mania um but the the article on
her com on her common sense sub stack
was called what the truckers want and
she interviewed they interviewed dozens
probably hundreds it said you know they
talked to hundreds of
truckers and protesters there and you
know the takeaway was there are plenty
of anti-vaxxers and people are like that
but a lot of them are very reasonable
people feel hurt feel left behind and
think this is the only thing they can do
how do we avoid this how do you solve
this what is the government to do what
are you thinking i i think the the
single biggest takeaway is that if it
can happen in canada it can certainly
happen just about anywhere
that's true and that if and that it's
going to happen at this scale in canada
um
so the the us prize itself on doing
things bigger and better uh i think
we're going to do it bigger and better
but when i say better i mean worse i
mean bigger like better from a
like a sensational point of view well
that there will be an order magnitude
yeah larger um gathering
what do you think on this
is um this is from a guy who wrote about
trucker convoys and training
you're somewhat of an expert oddly um
yeah
i i thought it was going to be because
we're automating the jobs way i did not
predict that it was going to be because
there's a pandemic that they didn't want
to be vaccinated against this is where i
struggle because i think there
if you have a certain type and this is a
small case i don't know how big the
population is but if you have a medical
condition
where you are like high risk high
variance for a variety of reasons
getting the vaccine yourself is a risk
right it's a risk it could kill you it
could have massively
negative side effects things like that
and that does not make you an
anti-vaxxer you can be the most liberal
person in the world right and you can
have that but if that's the case and you
work in a corporate office
who has a ma a vaccine
policy
you've gotta get two options you're
gonna get publicly shamed because and
not like so bad at the beginning but
you're gonna have to wear your mask and
everyone else won't be and they're going
to be more and more restrictions put on
you'll feel awkward you'll feel isolated
you'll feel like
uh i guess a trump supporter right like
no amount of virtue signaling can make
people feel like
uh you're not an anti-vaxxer not on
their team
or you live like you so you either live
like that as option one or option two
you have to find a new job like you have
to either work from home or or quit
right um and that's a number of the
folks that in very wise in that sub
stack were talking about where people
like i feel like my lifestyle's changed
just because i couldn't and many of them
couldn't or didn't want to get the facts
whether it's religious reasons or
medical reasons
to me
that can fuel like irrational thoughts
around it but there's a core rationality
there that does make sense to me as
someone who's pro-vaccine what are your
thoughts on how you avoid that prevent
that
handle that
some governments the ca there's a small
government
right now in canada that's like
look we're just going to come to a truce
here like we're going to get rid of this
saskatchewan right yeah um yeah
so it was a city sorry right um
or like a apartment yeah um
what do you
think on that because i you know this is
this is kind of the crux of it i think
you get rid of that you can actually
diffuse a lot of this bomb well the the
tough part is if you are a company or
you're a state
your interest is in trying to maximize
adoption
and so if you start being like hey
reasonable exception
will be made your adoption rate's going
to be lower yes uh and yeah
and so your incentives are to be like
look we're going to do this thing yeah
and there are significant number of
people who can be moved that direction
um and then there are going to be some
people that are like doesn't matter what
you say or do i'm not going to do it um
and so this happened in new york city i
don't know if you saw the story where uh
there was a mandate for city employees
yeah um and then
eric adams just announced he fired a
bunch i think it was something like 1400
1500 were fired
um now one of the byproducts of the
policy was that another you know several
thousand who didn't want to get
vaccinated did get vaccinated right
because they were like hey i don't feel
like not getting fired like it's not
worth it and then they got vaccinated um
and then you have these people lose
their job so in a way the policy
achieved its goal which is hey we got
adoption up um and then there are
these uh 1400 people that were like
doesn't matter not job not worth it to
me like i will go
um so if you're a government
or a very large company
these measures
make policy sense
and it's easier to increase adoption if
you take that line than if you're like
well let's do it case by case because
case in my case a lot of people will be
like well you know i i don't want to do
it and here are some reasons why and et
cetera
it's the winter it's a little bit gray
and yucky and so sometimes it's hard to
be upbeat sometimes it's hard to be
positive and when you do feel yourself
dragging sometimes you just say hey i'll
trudge through this but a lot of the
time you actually need some help and i
don't mean that friend who kind of
half-heartedly listens to you and
doesn't really give you true guidance
because that's honestly not what friends
are for i mean a professional therapist
and mental health resource i'm so proud
to be sponsored by betterhelp.com which
is helping over a million people take
charge of your mental health it's like
uber for therapists the person's on call
for you
all of the time
i want you to start living a happier
life today
and as a listener you'll get ten percent
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at bitterhelp.com
yang
join the hundreds of thousands of people
who have taken charge of their mental
health again that's betterhelphep.com
[Music]
you had a prediction this year which i
think i agree i agree with that cobit
will be over by the end of the year yes
but over was loosely defined right and
intentionally like we could define over
oh there will still be covid oh yeah
it's just that it's just that we're
um you know we're not going to be
oh you know we we won't be uh
restricting our own behaviors as much um
you know we will be gathering are we
creating
a new subset of extremes on the left and
the right here like are there gonna be
folks that forever or the next 10 20
years just always wearing masks and then
on on the right like never doing
anything the government says like are we
um or is this something maybe it's
because it's the attention economy like
something else will become the boogeyman
in
a year or so we're certainly
radicalizing people right now in a way
that's going to last and we're
traumatizing people in a way it's going
to last yeah i mean both those things
are true yeah yeah i mean like you know
one thing i'll say too as an asian
american yeah
asians were wearing masks uh pre-covered
routinely i don't know if you've ever
been over there yeah so
not in the united well some in the
united states but mainly in mainly in
asia right yeah where
asian just wore a mask for giggles
um well sars was a real thing right so
yeah so so here were the reasons why
asians wore masks
um one is that some of the places had a
lot of pollution so yeah
smog
another is that it is considerate to
your neighbors in any um moment in time
because hey if i have a cold i can't
infect you that's true uh yes yeah so so
that these were the the reasons
um why
uh also i think asian culture
prioritized less that i'm
like you know greeting you with a smile
kind of thing like it's not you know
it's just not as big a deal okay um so
in asian culture and massive a common
place anyway like if you fast forward
here in the united states x years from
now like they'll be a subset of people
wearing masks
yeah yeah i hate it i hate it a lot of
kids don't even remember not wearing a
mask yeah that makes sense which by the
way terrible for their development
terrible for their social development
yeah um do kids in asia wear the masks
or it's only adults mainly adults i
think kids wear them too if you're like
on the subway whatnot great
um yeah the numbers on this are are
awful and then
i don't know if you're a kid that's the
other thing we watch you watch super
bowl i'm assuming oh yeah you live
tweeted the super bowl that was fun um
congratulations to our folks in la
you probably didn't know you had a
football team until yes until
last sunday but we don't care congrats
sorry for the cincinnati fans um
if you're a kid in la you've got a mask
requirement in your school but you watch
super bowl and see all of these
celebrities and people
and your leaders if you're
old enough to understand who the mayor
of la is
not wearing masks in there um does that
teach him the wrong message i don't know
if you talk to your boys about this and
um
things like that i think we are past the
point where masks and schools make sense
from the data
the fact is that kids risk themselves
very low yeah
and
if you're a teacher and want to be
protected from transmission it's more
important that you're wearing a mask and
the kids are wearing a mask right
and it does have negative impacts on
kids ability to learn in their social
development
so
i think we should move beyond masks in
schools
but you know that there are individual
communities that are making a different
choice
i am open to certain communities having
it's like anything it's why we have
states right like if certain communities
want to make their own laws on that and
you
people do have relative flexibility to
move school districts and places
although it gets ugly or you know as you
as you spread out you know anyway
the the last takeaway on the the
canadian trucker convoy is that
i've read a lot of press that it's a
far-right movement and i don't think
that's
fully accurate and or it's not
particularly just an anti-vaxx movement
it's a fact anti-vaxx mandate movement i
believe but doesn't seem i think i'm
wondering if you agree with me it
doesn't seem
that it's far right it may be
conservative i think based on government
you know defense it depends on how you
define far-right i i would characterize
it as something of an anti-government
you can't protest and
is that the same thing as far right like
in some quarters maybe another court is
less so yeah occupy wall street was anti
establishment establishment and that
came from the left i guess yeah that got
weird
and i'm assuming this convoy will get
weird right now i'm sure many would say
if it was summer it would be weirder but
it's i think i'm pretty sure um
according to someone who's physically
been yeah it's like it's it's already
pretty um
it's like um there's a lot of weirdness
here in the u.s
and characterizing something is weird
doesn't necessarily mean it's not human
sympathetic
etc etc you know i mean like that's one
of the big problems with today is that
if you introduce me and this is my
friend steven said when he wrote an
article about it it's like like he met
these people or he saw them and they
were you know keep like disrupting
um the the neighborhood being so kids
couldn't sleep like da da and he felt
this like um anger and derision
towards them but then he you know he's
commenting on in a self-aware way
is that there's like a real impulse for
us to regard people in a certain
situation or a light and then say and
then feel that like anger or even worse
like disgust
um and i think that dehumanization is
really to be
avoided in oneself if you can one of the
things too it's like there are different
forms of marginalization and this is one
of the biggest problems in american life
right now it's like there are forms of
marginalization that certain segments of
society will be like oh we should care a
great deal about this form of
marginalization yes let's call it
um
gender race sexual orientation something
along those lines yeah um uh and then
they'd be like let's take this person
who
might be impoverished might be like
uneducated might have very little in the
way of
opportunities
but they're from a particular part of
the country they have a particular
affiliation maybe a certain set of
political beliefs um and
that person is marginalized too
uh in their way like if you grow up poor
in appalachia like i'm going to suggest
like you know you have it rough
um and
that
type of marginalization
like
not sympathetic at all right in the same
to at least to the the same group of
people right i mean recently i published
an op-ed about men and boys struggling
yeah this is a group
that
is not viewed sympathetically right
because they're more powerful than women
or even though by the numbers tons of
adversity tons of failure
uh you know only 40.5 percent of college
students less likely to finish high
school five times more likely to be in
juvenile detention like you know the
facts are very consistent and
troubling now i would never go so far as
to say like men are marginalized in the
same way it's like like that that's not
the suggestion um but if you were to
show me someone who
frankly like grew up in a poor part of
the country
um and would never have a chance to
advance meaningfully um regardless of
their
their race i'd be like yeah that person
you know yeah that person has a tough
and this is what happened to me on the
presidential too is that i would
occasionally
comment on for example the plight of
like people in rural communities um and
which by the way those communities are
being decimated um
and then and people would then attack me
as being like an alt-right white
supremacist and it's like i was not
aware that you could
be concerned about opiate deaths in
rural communities and like all of a
sudden that translates to you know white
supremacy and that's one of the problems
with the ideological polarization
they're going to be
extremes that come out of this
and they're going to be people that find
those extremes
uh
really really
unsympathetic
and it's one reason why
you know we should be deeply concerned
about what's coming well it's in reading
the way
trudeau is handling this and the
canadian government is handling this and
then reading stories from folks on the
ground my thought was this seems like a
lack of empathy where
okay
maybe a whole chunk of these folks don't
like the government or
or don't like this law and it's 20 of
your country but it's still 20
of the human beings that are citizens in
your country
and the left i thought was supposed to
be known for empathy and we're going
it's going the other way well this in
canada there's also like a high uh
premium placed on not
uh raising a ruckus and doing all this
stuff these people are you know kind of
fair canadians are nice generally
speaking nicer than us oh this is what
my canadian friend steven suggested he
was like look like we we don't get mad
in the same way but like like when
people are
fouling things up like there's like
actually like a reservoir
yeah i get it i guess right i mean i
understand they do it they have a
different relationship with their own
society
than we do there is like a higher level
of
uh trust
and and then so if someone's heading the
other direction then i think there's
like a fall in line or stop whereas in
the u.s this is one of the fundamental
problems like the trust is really really
low so if someone's like hey screw you
you're full of it da da da like you know
almost 50 percent of americans be like
yeah
so so it's a it's in our dna in the
sense that that the country started as a
revolution right it's uh you know we
split up i mean in some way everybody
who came here was
getting away from some sort of freedom
yeah totalitarian xyz right some
overreach and some or opportunity or
upside right that's i mean that's that
the country's story gets told to every
child right whether through their
parents or to the school so that's um
and that's why a lot of people and
across the world they feel pride in
their country those shared stories and
these are real
measurable things in many ways right so
um
we'll see how this happens yeah bold
prediction you know we'll we'll have our
own trucker convoys
um that will be bigger and probably way
more destructive uh and probably over
nothing to do with trucking i don't know
um or if we wait long enough that's
something to do with truckee
[Music]
a topic that we got a lot of comments on
in the youtube section was video games
and men
um
and i was looking up numbers
video games have been more and more
appealing to women or like not that
they're more appealing
hold bar but it's about 50 of gamers 55
of gamers
are men 45
women and that's
fluctuated but generally going up um but
i do think men fill a void more than
women are filling a void with their with
their gaming in video games so i don't
know if um you grew up gaming a bit
right yes um
did you use did you ever see it as part
of your identity in that sense or part
of your masculinity that's like a weird
deep question but i'm curious oh yeah
for sure uh so i i grew up playing um
atari 2600 and then calico vision and
then nintendo what's colleague elvis oh
i had it it was a it was an interim uh
platform didn't last long um what was
your favorite arcade games street
fighter 2 mortal kombat a lot of the
combat games so when you talk about my
masculinity part of my identity was that
i was very very good at street fighter 2
as one example
like i would beat people you were good
you were notorious amongst your friends
for being that good yes and and then if
someone came and beat me it was like a
real blow to my ego oh interesting um so
uh
and then i did play world crafts what's
that on yeah
arcades and play and then warcraft
starcraft there are the real-time
computer right um and then it that
became world of warcraft which is a
massive multiplayer online role-playing
game that became a thing um so i did i i
played
world of warcraft enough to
understand the appeal and love it but
not enough so that i went that deep into
it and that generation of game
um then
has become the mainstay standard where
you go uh dota um which is another
um
uh
similar game i think someone's going to
yell i mean i compared dota world of
warcraft i i you know the high level
concept is similar right is what you're
saying that the yeah so you you log on
you have a person who can level up
progressively you play with other real
humans who you interact with
um and so it can give you community
and advancement yes uh and
structure and uh purpose and like a lot
of other things people play video games
with a in a healthy amount and they
don't get addicted which that's also a
thing but they get their better social
skills they have better mental health
there's a number of things
which i don't we could talk about but
that's not really the point keep going
sorry no so um so i played enough video
games to love them and there was an
extended period of my life where i
thought anytime i was going to have lots
of time in my hands i'd be like oh i'd
play a bunch of video games got it um
now that
uh that idleness has not happened to me
because i've just been freaking busy
for for like uh um a long time
um
but i felt like i
got games uh to a higher degree than
maybe someone who hadn't spent years
playing them right um
and i understand their deep appeal to
boys and men
um because
uh they're the kind of things that
give you the positive feedback that you
seek
almost all the time where if i put time
in i'm gonna get better i'm going to
gain stature i'm going to get
relationships like you know i almost
can't help but it but but gain those
things
so whereas if you do a job
uh
you know sometimes the
positive feedback or reinforcement
doesn't follow the effort that's the
crux that's actually what i'm talking
about and that i think a lot of people
are equating
male idleness and it tends to be tends
to be male idleness but i guess you
could have female idolists too um but
idleness with gaming well so this is one
thing too that uh you know it is just
documented fact
um women deal with idleness better than
men do correct in terms of
evidence pro-social behaviors exhibit
one
out of work women much more likely to go
back to school than out of work men have
you ever had anyone fight you on that i
think that's anecdotally no no those are
those are documented facts oh yeah my
boys like even but like i don't think
that cuts against a narrative we all see
every day like i think most of the guys
i know when they go yeah yeah they kind
of self-destruct right it's or they go
through a rough pot how many times you
know a guy going through a rough patch
over a girl well so jobless jobless guys
number one they volunteer at lower
levels than guys who have jobs so think
about that i have more time i volunteer
less less yep um my video game computer
use consumption goes up
my alcohol consumption goes up yep my
levels of drug use and gambling go up so
pretty much any social ill you can
identify is going to go up if you give
us more time if you give us more time oh
god there's a world where video games
are massively positive because they're
keeping men from becoming
idle in a sense like i have a number of
friends from you know a couple i'll
speak one in particular like he's a he's
a successful teacher his wife works he's
got a bunch of kids they take a couple
vacations a year he's got a pretty good
life but i imagine like the job is like
remotely fulfilling like it's fine but
he loves the game and that gives him his
own like different things he's not
getting in the real world right where
it's like different type of community
new people the sense of development and
purpose and goal setting and things like
that
in my opinion you'd rather have
my friend like that focusing on a video
game than trying to get those sense of
purpose and accomplishment and goal
setting
in some of the more destructive ways he
could be spending his time he'd probably
be gambling which could be gambling it
could be drinking i mean look he could
get the same amount of fulfillment with
a bible study or a group of guys hanging
out watching sports and other things
right he could he could also get them
from
awful things right or just not get them
or just not well then and if he doesn't
get them then he would come out in
certain ways yeah yeah it probably would
and i think
i don't think we talk about that enough
right um because i think there's an im
there's a
connotation that if you're playing video
games you're not being productive and i
know that i play sports video games like
i or
my brother-in-law's one of my favorite
things to do when i was living with my
roommate here in new york we'd come back
and play nba 2k yes in college i played
so far all the time i play madden now i
love it my brother loves fifa my brother
and i somebody growing up my brother and
i we love video games we were like you
know boys kids in the 90s early 2000s um
so like
wayne gretzky's 3d hockey and then was
one of my first like i think that was
n64 my brother loved donkey kong all
nintendo games and mainly he was
exceptional at most mario games so there
was a period of time where he like had a
summer off and he was
globally ranked in mario kart like on
the wii so that's ridiculous year
younger than me he was like
22 when he did it um
but
um and we still have fun playing video
games for once a while but um
if you're just playing like that like
either mario racing or
like fifa or stuff you there's an
argument that that's kind of idleness
because it's not a lot of social
interaction there's not a lot of team
building it's very different than call
of duty or world of warcraft or some of
these others and i think we probably
should understand the difference um
because you can't have guys just rotting
some of them maybe have a twitch stream
and have found a way to monetize it
but most don't i imagine by the numbers
um
is the solution
for these types of men either better
video games right if they're just like
[ __ ] around on fifa all the time
um
is it better for them to be playing a
different type of community game to get
some purpose and fulfillment or should
we be happy that these men are i mean
frankly not shooting up schools and not
going into dark youtube rabbit holes and
getting
polarized and i think if you play uh
a game like fifa that's self-contained
and isn't like part of this massive
universe i think it's just as healthy
um in a way it might be
um like a lower commitment because you
just go you you know you better matches
and then you like you know you go back
whereas if you do join one of these
massive uh multiplayer online
role-playing games
it can be a real commitment you know you
it's true you can't like half-ass it
yeah you dip your toe in and then you're
behind everyone else like they're all
super power and you're like oh
you know and then when people find you
you're they're like why don't you have
any upgrades
and they're sucking your wallet too
because it's you gotta pay
yeah exactly so so so i i think
different games suit different ends
um i i do think that um you could
design games to be able to serve certain
goals
um right now the the like a
well-designed game gets you hooked
um because you are developing relatively
quickly and directly yeah i i think
there's probably a sweet spot in terms
of the consumption of these games there
is a tendency to over consume for
certain folks you know china has just
cracked down on the hours where like
they limit it right they limit it in a
way that you know just people here would
be like that that's crazy i think the
rule
is that you're only allowed to game play
for something like
three hours a week i mean someone can
look it up
which by the way is essentially the
polar opposite of what was going on like
people were i think gaming for you know
50 hours a week and then it just somehow
got very very quickly turned around
imagine working in that industry they
announced this at the end of august to
limit gamers under the age of 18 to
playing only between the hours of 8pm
and 9pm on fridays saturdays and sundays
oh yes three hours
nice so that's for miners so that's
under the age of 18.
um it sounds like after you turn 18 then
all bets are off i'm not sure if that's
true
here in the us it's just whatever serves
the market's interests
is the major default and then if you get
in the way of that then everyone gets
mad
um so right now obviously the game
gaming companies would very much dislike
having a
limit on how much miners can play oh
yeah um
so is there a sweet spot
i think you know i mean i i it seems
like
uh you know the the us um is probably at
one extreme where there are a lot of
miners i'm sure that are addicted to
games in a way that
is
likely uh making it less likely that
they
go out and succeed and prosper in the
real world
[Music]
i'm sure some of these games replace
certain parental figures um if you have
a lot of you have a lot of kids broken
homes like the video game becomes either
their community or where they learn
right and wrong and other things they're
not learning from mom or dad um
do you have advice for parents
what you've done for your boys to help
them navigate
let's call it the addictiveness of video
games or screen time or
things like that so first let me say i'm
not um the role model on this where my
my kids love them some roblox
and uh
that they
would prize it over any other way to
spend their time
no i think that the best thing you could
do in an ideal world would be to
uh spend spend time with them
in pursuits that get them out about and
develop confidence in different ways
but that's unrealistic for a lot of
parents and families because you're
working you're busy
uh you know like the easiest thing is
just to give the kid a screen and have
them and by the way they're happier with
you and so you're like yeah then yeah
you know and then you know what you do
you turn on your own screen you're like
oh i guess i'll catch up on uh
you know some stuff you said this on the
trail that parents are outgunned um
my my parents used to um my dad was an
engineer so it's very systematic but we
used to have uh reward systems so if i
it was simple sometimes if i read for 30
minutes or if i clean the bathrooms or
if i did xyz chores then i would earn a
certain amount of tv time which was good
but the for my brother and i was like we
tried to get my parents where they would
like forget to enforce the limit so it's
like oh you get 30 minutes of tv time
and if my mom got distracted with
something else i'd squeeze that into 45
or an hour um or try
and that's the hardest part it's like
it's parenting it's
hand combat you know it's like it's uh
it's difficult and to you like
we're wired too in this way you know you
want your kid to have some screen time
and uh you need some as well so it's
tough to set a good example too it is
tough so the single biggest thing you
should be pushing for yourself or your
kids or whomever loved ones is just a
sense of moderation
now the the ideal thing and this will
happen to you or to me
um where the real world demands stuff of
you and of me and so you're like getting
pulled in that way so it was not
realistic for me to frankly like you
know play games for like uh x hours a
day you know like uh um now because i
have all these demands now if you were
to get rid of all these demands then all
of a sudden it'd be like oh
so so in many ways the the challenge is
to make the real world more
demanding of a draw you know more
relationships more needs and and whatnot
or at least in tandem with
the
gaming and the virtual world
and the upside of the metaverse
theoretically right
yeah you know there are and to your
point i mean
this isn't like a pure good pure bad
it's just like
can it be something that there's too
much of yes um you know like
if you can moderate something
um and make it a part of your life the
way your friend has or or whatnot i
think that's reasonable
goal for us to set yeah
i think it's something interesting if
men aren't getting that sort of purpose
their their reason well here's what the
studies have shown the studies have
shown that playing games is awesome
and good studies and that and that
you're happy playing the games but the
studies have shown that your
satisfaction with uh playing the games
declines in your mid late 20s and then
it starts to become less
positive and wholesome and fun and a lot
of people are moving on and by the way
like i've seen this in people i'm close
to
and the main
reason for your all of a sudden clicking
in and being like okay like i'm in the
game this happened to me too like i was
gaming gaming and then eventually i was
like oh no and you know like the single
biggest thing for me was like oh i'm i'm
i'm gonna try and date a woman find a
relationship yeah um and there was an
instinctive part of me that was like i
don't know if they're going to be into
the gaming thing i mean some women do
accommodate it yeah so it drove me in a
particular direction at that point and
so the studies have shown that this is a
very consistent pattern the social perks
and incentives to not be gaming all the
time are pretty high at a certain age
and so that's the threshold time
where if someone then ventures out into
the real world and let's say they find
something completely unwelcoming and
inhospitable then they'll be like all
right [ __ ] that and then go back to
gaming and then and then the gaming
satisfaction will also decline over time
and then you know like this is not a
great track right um when they go out
into the world and they're like okay hey
what's out here like you know do i have
opportunities relationships progression
and they get that then they're like okay
like i can i can follow this so when
that boy or man
reaches out and tries to head down that
direction
uh what do they find yes and if they
don't find i mean if they put themselves
out there and they find themselves
rejected or embarrassed
or
questioned their masculinity or man
manhood whatever it is they fail
then it seems a lot safer to go back to
video games sure that doesn't mean some
of these video games aren't like
productive and helpful and they can
learn certain things but it's also
like over time that they have
diminishing marginal returns right it's
not great it's not a great outcome for
yeah i had a chapter on this that if you
want if you're looking for this like the
article's posted somewhere but there's a
chapter in the war on normal people
called video games and the parenthetical
male meaning of life yeah it is going to
be a growing force
in uh people's lives particularly here
in america you know we just have to try
and make it as positive as possible make
the real world as positive as possible
and make the metaverse as positive as
possible right i mean the way i see it
you have to give them better
options than video games or you have to
make the video games connect to real
life more right you might have some
for-profit incentives for the latter
there and again if there's a loved one
or you yourself just try and
um
play in moderation you know that's how
you play amen you know my test when i
was gaming
have i been frozen in position for so
long that i have a body part that hurts
very logical of you yeah yeah i have the
same i am or am i hurting myself
tomorrow by playing today it was like a
big and it's the delayed gratification
it's a marshmallow test for kids that i
think is important right you know i
heard this one where it's yeah yeah we
delayed gratification i'll give you one
marshmallow now or two in five minutes
tell you for the for those of you at
home who remember this stuff it's fine
and no one does whatever uh i had a
callus on my left hand
from doing the uh are you can street
fighter 2 motion so much because it
involves a joystick in a semi-circle to
the right i did it so many times
that i i developed a callous below my
left middle finger and i'm touching it
right now to see if it's still there
it's still there i mean maybe you should
have you touching the seat dude i think
it's still there
i mean you can see it comparably the
left to the right all right look at that
man
that's your video game scars my video
game counts point of pride man point of
pride i've i [ __ ] ruled as
ken ryu but i was uh disconcertingly
effective balrog which totally screwed
everyone up because they were like
balrogs terrible but you found his but i
i found a way to win with balrog where
i'm just going to geek out for a minute
please so okay so balrog is the boxer
not a good character okay so if you were
playing like canon ryu you could
generally you'd think you could just
like fireball him into submission but
what he did have is he had a power
where he could actually
uh spin through a fireball and punch you
if you timed it perfectly um it's
difficult a time i was very good with
him but i still couldn't know but you
know when i could time it the beginning
of the round so so the early on so so
the beginning of the round i would hold
all three punch buttons down and then
whoever i'm fighting nine times out of
ten they're going to do a fireball um so
so they do the fireball and i time
through it
so then i punched them and then they're
just like what just happened i just did
like a customary opening
and i just got punched
so then their next move
is like they don't fireball again
because they're now afraid i'm just
gonna do it again right so then they
jump in the air to do like a jumping
kick which is like the next most uh like
basic effective thing this is how i went
and then i'm expecting it so
so
so
so then i did a rushing uppercut that
would punch them out of the air so at
this point then they're they're like you
know often like
half the time i'd be able to get a third
shot in and because i'd hit him three
times in succession they'd be dazed for
a second and then you you'd so so like
the rounds like two thirds over um
and then the rest of it you know i'm
like effective well the other thing is
that the guy had the equivalent of the
guile sonic boom attack where if you did
like the left hold right punch he did a
punch that took a little bit of damage
that you know even if you blocked it so
i just be like doing that over and over
again just like screwed people up so it
just does a number on someone's
confidence so bad if you remember
vividly was this is your teenage years
or is this this college man i'd gotta go
to college and just play street fighter
2 in the student center
it was mostly asian dudes anyone who is
my age
most mostly asian dudes there was this
really
uh good black dude with dreads who'd
come and he'd play and he was excellent
he would beat me half the time but
there's like no shame in losing to him
is it like he was really is it like you
know basketball where like you if you
lose you get off the machine oh yeah
yeah totally started so you play credits
and then if you're really good you play
all day each day and then people just
keep chum challenging you i love that
your mommy dude we had
you and i had such different college
experiences man i don't think i played
street fighter once
well i mean dude i'm like x years older
than you i mean i went to school between
uh i went to school in the like early to
mid 90s i will say i played super smash
bros and i did love that and i was very
good with star fox because he had that
he had that move that you could like you
would jump and then do like a real quick
direction like left to right and i was
very good at like i was just jumping no
one was coming and then mid jump i just
direct right at him and hit him and then
he had pretty good shield pretty good
gun didn't think we'd be talking about
this very exciting glad you knew the
glad you have calluses from your video
game my street fighter day zoom oh my
gosh that's amazing okay
that is it is it anyway exciting stuff
from andrew and zach today yes i'm proud
of us i'm pumped about i'm pumped about
audrey's discord you can join a discord
without having nft so we'll tweet about
it
lobby3.io click the link it'll be fun
see you monday
yeah yes oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you